hello and welcome back to nintendo
treehouse live i'm brandon from the
nintendo treehouse
and i'm joined by teresa and rob and
kaye
and we are going to show you a little
bit of mario golf super rush which is
coming out on the nintendo switch system
very soon
uh only in a couple of weeks teresa you
are our driver
pun intended uh so uh why don't you kick
us off here why don't you why don't you
uh start with play golf show us what's
what's what's in store sure
uh so we're gonna go through several
modes but we're gonna start with
standard golf
because as it's in the name it's your
standard
experience it makes sense yeah we're
gonna
play with the nintendo switch pro
controller and we're gonna go with two
players
rob will you be my plus one absolutely i
will thank you
we're gonna do uh the format stroke play
and take turns so then we can see
um the full visibility of the screen you
can do
let me back it out you can do all at
once which is
a new feature for offline in this game
uh before
it was an available nintendo 3ds
version of the mario golf game um and it
was available online so
this is really cool that we get to try
it out offline now
yeah i love this roster of playable
characters look at how amazing all the
outfits look yeah look like luigi
so dapper mario's pants are such a
choice
it it might be all the choices he's
take all the boxes it's like a flowchart
those are those are
colors that are together
i also i'm also very fond of bowser
junior's visor i think that is a very
good fashion choice
and look at bowser's senior here with
his like black and red
oh yeah ensemble very very very faith
and there's that visor
clown car advisor is great everyone
who are we actually playing that's who
we're going to bring to the green on
this i'm going to go with mario
this is the og sensible choice uh i'm
going to go with the other og pauline
nice ah so this is pauline's first
appearance in mario golf
hopefully she brings a little bit of
expertise she is the mayor of a major
city so hopefully she's played a few
games of golf before that sounds like
it's probably
you know part of her repertoire so
that's my secret strategy
it's a good one so we're gonna play wild
weather woods
um and what's really interesting about
this course is that
there's uh natural hazards that will
affect your gameplay and you need to
account for
so there's different courses in mario
golf
super rush where all
each course will have its own little uh
conditions
and it makes gameplay very very
interesting um
starting off on a pretty sunny day here
in wild weather woods but as the name
implies that might change
yeah so it's a it's a clear sunny
day moderate wind lots of trees yeah
moderate wind
seven miles per hour uh sort of a
westerly wind just enough to be annoying
so you could see right underneath
pauline's name there's a little flag
indicator with two
uh downward facing uh
arrows that means that the flag is
downhill so that's something we need to
take account for
um i'm gonna turn here to an overhead
view
and you can see that as i change the
clubs the distance changes as well
so the carry which is the distance that
the ball will
go through fly thank you um will change
and then that little
white kind of um transparent line is
where the ball will roll or
run so that is your potential max
distance you can travel if it does roll
all the way to the end of that
transparent line correct so
i want to account for that wind that's
going westward
so i think i'm good i don't want to
watch out for that tree though
yeah hopefully the wind carries it away
i think i can
i can go over it so you'll see my shot
gauge kind of go up and down so the
first hit is for me to start the shot
but the second hit
is for me to set the power of the shot
nice shot i'm gonna go for it oh
oh cleared the tree very nice very very
nice i believe
[Laughter]
you're just showing off for us now nice
nice
golf claps golf clubs for a good shot
all right
so now you'll notice that um mario could
get a little farther than pauline could
and that's because
all the characters are different stats
uh pauline is
good at other things mario has a little
more driving distance um
i'm going to yeah i think that's
probably a good spot to enforce right
between those trees
yeah what is your mayoral instinct tell
you rob
[Laughter]
hit the ball and pray nice shot very
nice shot
yeah all right that was nice nice you
guys are off to a good start
i traveled a fair bit too yeah got to go
again since you're farther back yep
notice the little bitty buds there
they're acord
they're both a course hazard and a
course opportunity if you
hit one you get a coin which helps fill
up your meter but um
they can throw off the ball an adorable
hazard they're a horrible hazard they
can throw off your ball
like but sometimes it could be in a
positive direction where it can get you
closer to the flag
so you'll notice also that my sorry
um my shot gauge is a little bit curved
here and that's because of the way that
the ball is lying
that's great and i got these red uh
triangles here to show me that i try to
get my maximum power
i lose a little bit of control in the
process there's so much helpful visual
information just like that like that
little slight curve just
helps you out so much oh yeah
that worked out really well very well
look how beautiful that was
thank you stay on the green stay on the
green stay on the oh a little bit too
much power
it's just slightly too much power just
wants to see what's over there yeah all
right
you're still in good shape though i need
to count for that wind that's going
northwest just a little seven miles just
a little bit
okay and
i want to go a little bit less
because i want to hit i want to get
closer to that flag
yeah so i'm going to do a spin
a backspin to minimize the run of the
ball
so when i set i start the shot
i'm gonna set for that backspin right
there
i'm holding my breath i know yeah
it looks very promising very what a good
setup
very genuine golf club yeah genuine what
have you been doing until now brandon
okay all right so this is yeah
pretty straightforward i've got a little
bit of a downhill to the left going on
the green
so i'm going to try and compensate for
that you're also chipping and not
putting
yeah but if you wanted to switch to your
putter you could i could but that feels
like wasted effort in the rough
that was probably a little too much a
little too strong it was a lot too much
power but you did get it out of the
rough
i did get it out of the way nice
recovery
set up for a long putt but you know i've
seen people make it in from farther yeah
yeah and looks like between me and
theirs is pretty
pretty straightforward a little bit of a
uphill
that you have to yeah fight through i
love the way that that overhead view and
even the grid we're looking at now
changes when you switch to putting to
let you know exactly what the typography
is
yeah what do you have to account for the
moving arrows and and the
the colors really make it easy to tell
at a glance what you're looking at
yeah no it's still me okay
because i'm still farther that's cool i
think this is the one that's right
all right there we go that looks good
hit the hole thanks it's because this
hill is uphill
this is a very tricky green yeah it
definitely
because it's uphill it will give a
little bit of a curve to your
to the ball so all right
all right show us what you're looking
for all right no this is you're you're
up for a birdie no pressure
very well done very good job
okay now because the game is uh if you
get within a certain range of the whole
the game just says yeah tap
in you don't actually have to do
anything skillful though very good
[Laughter]
that is a very satisfying thing pauline
you still have two more holes that's
right
three more holes you still got game
still got game
she's playing the long game
[Laughter]
all right so hole two uh par
three so we want three strokes or less
um and the wind is going south
west a little bit stronger than the last
quarter so something to keep in mind
so because i'm still going to be
a little bit too far i want to give a
little bit more
run on my and i want to account for that
wind too
it's 11 miles per hour so you definitely
want to count for that wind
yeah that's that that looks good
and then i'm gonna add some topspin
nice shot let's hope you don't roll off
the edge into the water
yeah i'm gonna fast forward to see where
this goes
oh very nice very nice well done
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna try
and uh oh you're actually out of my
range i was gonna try and use my special
shot to knock you out but
i can't reach you i think you should
still you can try
or you could save it for the next one
i'll save it for the next hole
that's probably why so that's a good
strategy
of course now i've tipped my hand that's
true
that's true well we'll talk about
special shots here in a bit because they
are
they are as in the name special indeed
all right well done yes
all right
no pressure right that's quite a long
putt though
it is along with a lot of dips yeah
there's downhill
and you're also fighting the wind yeah
all right a lot of factors at play here
but of course as we know if you go too
hard
so close i was demonstrating that
a little bit too much a little bit too
much
it's a very delicate balance it is a
very delicate balance
let's see
am i maybe a little bit too much
all right i'm hoping here
oh that looks good nope no
too much it was too much yeah they're
just warning the flag they wanna
let it know yeah all right i should have
gone straight
that's okay i think this is this looks
pretty pretty flat where you're at
yeah okay very nice
very good good job thank you
see if i can save this
i like that the music changes when
you're putting too
yeah i could like probably amped up the
tension a little bit
yeah that made me nervous my palms are
sweaty
that sounds like golf stuff yep
all right so last hole uh par four
you've gotten really lucky with the
weather yeah it's really sunny because
in wild weather woods there does get
some storm clouds and actual thunder so
the thunder can mess up with your
strokes
you could get electrified which
uh if you're careful yeah it does mess
with your game
um so i'm gonna go a little bit
play a little bit differently here yeah
i think that's smart
um south westerly wind
i'm gonna move it a little bit there and
i'm gonna
i'm gonna minimize the backspin okay so
it looks like like you're trying to
avoid do a little shorter and avoid the
trees so you can have a straight shot at
the flag
correct i want to avoid there's like
four trees
for me to account for so i definitely
want to get a clear shot of the flag to
i'm coming close to those bitty bits
yeah those bitty buds
okay and i think that's a pretty good
idea
i'm going to copy off your paper oh
i see how this is so it's a battle of
technique it is
yeah you're going to shoot right into
the rough though uh maybe not
i i didn't think so yeah just checking
it's just psyching this out
[Laughter]
but go for the rough rob
it's a game of psychology as well as uh
typical golf stuff yeah golf stuff yeah
golf stuff
i think this might hit the bitty buds
though
oh miraculous save for the biddy bud
lucky day for this was very lucky
oh i'm a little bit still too close
to the tree how's that overhead view
oh boy oh now you're going to get a
chance to show off a curved shot though
teresa
it might be yeah all right should we do
altitude
add some altitude yeah yeah or i can do
a special shot
yeah you know what those those bars at
the top are always so ready for golf
yeah look at the fire man's action
let's just try yeah your meters up at
the top are full and kind of commanding
our attention so i would love
to share a little bit of the special
shots yeah it might be a game changer
let's find out shall we i know
all right all right so every character
has a different special shot
mario's will arc and then land oh very
well done
you can see that impact as the ball
landed there that would have knocked
another ball out of the way
yeah all right luckily pauline wasn't
there yet
well yeah
yeah i don't want to go quite that far
though
yeah that looks good
all right
she's ready too she's so ready oh she's
so talented
oh i love her and because pauline goes
a little lower on her arch she missed
the branches on the leaves that could
have messed up with her
stroke so that was well played yeah i
think that was a very good shot given
that you were directly in front of a
tree
yeah i'm very impressed that somebody's
not very good at golf
so the flag is uphill there's a little
blue arrow
in the little flag indicator so that's
something rob will need to account for
and since rob's in the rough you can see
that the red
arrows have lengthened
wow wow there's that mayoral expertise
don't wow long game yeah
literally is speechless
[Laughter]
well i'm a little bit thrown off here
um so i have to battle uphill but also
a slight westerly wind very slight
all right
maybe a little bit just a lot of power
yeah
it's too strong oh no that was
not good play on my heart
talk about a long putt my goodness long
uphill putt yep
this is where the probably too much club
though come in handy
think like a mayor
[Laughter]
think like a mayor municipal bonds
oh so close i
have done bad judgment calls this is on
me it is not on mario
it is on me i will say that it is very
satisfying whenever it hits the flag in
any way
unless it bounces off of it and rolls
away
right i guess that doesn't matter it
does make you think you're gonna hit it
oh it's okay mario it's okay your score
overall is still
really good yeah so i'm close enough
here to the hole that the game is not
going to make me do any kind of meter or
anything i just hit the button there we
go and i tap in
nice par well done rob well done
beautiful
wow that birdie earlier saved me
yeah that was a good round of golf yeah
nice congratulations very good thank you
hey good sport good sportsmanship
i concur all right so let's move on to
golf adventure i would love really cool
mode i love to see and share golf
adventure
so we're gonna start off with rob smee
because
i had planned for him to lose
rob's adventure starts from the very
beginning uh he starts as
a rookie golf club um golfer
and he'll start here in the dormitory
the little
birdo
um and we're at bonnie green's which
happens to be
the birthplace of golf for the mushroom
kingdom
love that little tidbit love that we get
to go to the place the sport originated
in in mario's world that's very cool
yeah everything
looks and all the characters are
interactable so you see the little
speech bubbles here
yeah yeah and they all have interesting
things to say
some have tips some throw shade like
this guy on the bench that i just i love
him so much
oh really yeah
[Laughter]
that's a good sass good day no he's
trying to say helpful things
he has an attitude about it he has a
hard time making friends you know
all right very relatable we're gonna go
explore
the country club and we're gonna go
here to the right um
where is the cafe everybody's uh
enjoying really yummy meals oh the pink
shy guy
it's a little slice of life in the
mushroom kingdom just hanging out and
i'm such a sucker for that rob i'm so
like any time that you get to see
mushroom kingdom inhabitants just
hanging out in the free time
playing some golf living their best life
locker rooms
give them their privacy go straight into
the store
um and i i love this part so uh when
you're a rookie you're given
a preset uh golf clubs
and as you keep going through the golf
adventure you'll get in-game currency
which you'll be able to spend on
additional inventory so golf clubs
including this
wacky curvy draw five hybrid
it's a banana fade five or a banana draw
five hybrid either one they're both
classic golf clubs normal golf stuff
real real things
definitely exist it really adds to those
curved shots
um and also a tire which has stats that
can really help in your adventure
and also very stylish very stylish look
at those pants
these are this is where uh i love
uh spending my money on because i can't
control myself
so but it's for the sport
it's for the sport it's money well spent
but unfortunately rob
doesn't is still in the beginning of his
adventure so not able to purchase those
yet so we're going to follow the red
arrow
the top right of the screen also tells
you indicates what a mission or quest
you're on
which the red arrow attributes to so
we're going to follow it to this guy
with the exclamation point
he's enthusiastic
[Laughter]
i don't expect a hammer brother to be
chill do you
fair fair point
i'll need 60 points to pass this lesson
okay okay that sounds doable
sounds doable yeah
all right so uh
my goal is to hit the ball all the way
to that pie chart over there
um and you see that circle there's
different segments i
want to aim for the blue because blue
gives me the most points
i'm gonna test to see the distance here
let's see
how much power i have to hit the ball in
order to get to
10. why that much power wow
that was exactly what you needed you're
a natural wow
what if i did too much nice
i'm out of curiosity i'm just wondering
how far it rolls that's what these
practice rounds are for right
to get a good feel for your power
oh too much control of the ball so this
this exercise of course is for
practicing your drives there's a bunch
of other exercises for
uh other kinds of you know putting and
other ex skills
so you can focus on the part of the game
that's giving you trouble if something
is
yeah and for any reason say that you
advance
that was a little bit too weak on my
part for any reason that you advance
through the adventure and you feel like
oh i want more practice at a specific
lesson you could always backtrack and do
these lessons again
another good shot thanks golf clubs for
these
excellent shots
[Music]
go rob go wow it's
like i'm right there it's rob doing the
work here
i'm controlling him rob you're doing so
well thank you
it comes so naturally and easy mixing up
on you
oh just when you thought you got the
hang of it
they did all right like hey we heard you
like sand
they put a bunker there just for you wow
it's for you so have fun
go with full power and see how far the
shot goes
i like to look at that that looks pretty
good
pretty promising
oh look at that right at the edge now
you're just showing off
another thing i could do is add some
spin
to make the ball roll so have the its
run
go a little bit farther um or she didn't
do it
i didn't i was talking about it and i
confused myself so i
i deserve that seven competitive play
even against yourself
all right i'm gonna do it this time
there you go
topspin yeah so i set it as i'm setting
um the power of my shot uh one thing i
did mention too is that indicator on the
bottom of the screen
it looks like a little curve it's really
cool to see
just the distance that your ball travels
as well as
the the um the run of it of the ball
so let's see so i noticed on that last
shot it did roll further because of the
top spin
yeah i still need a little bit more
power
yeah so there's the the distance travel
the carry and then the roll the run of
the ball that's a lot of golf terms
trees
doesn't play a lot of golf i don't funny
enough
um i learned through mario called super
rush i'm not kidding
um since i hit the 60 score i'm going to
backtrack or back out of this lesson
i've obviously
been able to complete it and you've
proved your mastery of this i have
but i do want to show another thing as
the rookie
and in addition to the golf clubs you
also get a golf watch
golf watch does a lot of different
things shows you the map
shows you stats so as you progress
through the adventure you'll get
experience points and then you get to
put those points wherever you want
love golf with experience points all
your inventory
this area this is where i learned a lot
of my golf
uh terminology as well as golf adventure
yes it's a single player mode
great place for you to learn and
practice and just
get uh into the nitty gritty and learn
from the basics up perfect gradual curve
soon
you will you will be more knowledgeable
than toad is yes
you'll also get a plus one in your golf
skills
um and then the adventure diary diary
which will change
as uh you um or will progress
as you progress in the story too so
we're gonna
back out speaking of progressing in the
story yes
segway segway we're getting
segway so miami is level 51 because i've
done a lot of progression through golf
adventure
a lot of progression
and the the red arrow is pointing
backwards but i do want to come over
here we're in a different area it's
balmy dunes so
the course is here it's very dry very
deserty which
you would expect there's quicksand which
is something that you need to account
for
um and there's also because it's a
desert you need to account for
your water intake so i'm gonna go to the
vendor here just to show the different
inventory that they have
still that banana fade and banana draw
driver yep it's so popular um popular
but here's some new attire some cool
attire
yeah that i want to change into because
i
happen to purchase it because again i
lack self-control
for the sport yes yes
uh so see i'm gonna put on cool attire
reduces my water loss
that is pretty very important and desert
shoes
all right so we're going to follow the
arrow now so we're ready for some
uh gulf in the desert we're going to
cool a tire east
adventury golf it's the best kind of
golf
oh who is this who is speaking to us
theresa so this is a friendly voice uh
that gifted me their power which was the
lightning sword
in order to acquire a powerful item that
will allow me to face
more powerful foes like i said a lot of
golf terms
yeah it's all standard golf you know
there's a little quick time event here
and i immediately get the item that i
i was looking for the fire gem
oh yeah nice that's always a good thing
no downsides
hello oh but someone is not happy with
me
obtaining said item yeah
they look pretty menacing look look at
this
golf
uh so this is a boss battle i angered
the sacred flame beast um doesn't
mention because we're in the desert
i have to account for the water so my
water intake is
reducing as you can see at the top right
that's where that cool attire comes in
handy correct yeah
or top left you're right um and you'll
see these
uh purple circles on the ground those
are
the boss's attacks after run to these
electric uh circular items and
hit the sacred flame beast oh no it's a
little bit short
so i'm gonna dash by holding the b
button and you'll see my stamina bar
depleting depleting yeah when i'm not
using it
you are cutting it very close yeah oh
good job
okay okay so the water acts as
your life total basically during this
boss fight yes attacks drain a lot of
water
yeah hot in the desert it is oh oh no
even hotter when you get hit by a
fireball
so here's the quick stand that i was
talking about so i'm going to jump to
try to get out of it
and you can see the location of those
little lightning balls that
marked by exclamation points on the map
correct so that's handy
oh right in between these colors oh my
gosh
nice work all right so now i have to go
all the way across
to get to i'm going to do a special dash
i like that you're kind of just playing
chicken with it as you stand in the
middle of its purple attack area where
it is oh there it is
she's playing sacred flame beast with it
right yes
yes i think
the same dimensional beast looks angrier
than
ever yeah so now where where do i go
oh there right there oh hello
super happy to be fighting this sacred
hobby do you understand the situation
you're in
hurry up he's having a good time i need
to wait for the boss to power this
shot to hit it back and oh nice nice
golf glass wow thank you
that was exciting so i
completed my my quest and i've got a lot
of experience
and i'll be able to put that into
different stats so
i'm gonna do speed spin
sure that sounds good to me nice choices
lock those
um and one cool thing that i want to
mention is that
yes i'm playing my me in the story mode
but or
golf adventure but i'm also able to play
my me in other modes
including online so you'll be able to
face other players with their
very powerful means but there will be
exceptions so just just to point that
out if you want to set up a match so
that no one can use their knees that's
cool too
yeah i'm so happy that we get to see
more of our boys here wario and waluigi
i know they don't look like they're
enjoying the desert too much though
but they look good while they're doing
it they look good and that's the
important thing
they could have worn some cool attire
though i think they are
i may argue waluigi is anyway
they didn't get the memo
all right so that was just a little
sneak peek of a boss battle in
south adventure very exciting so there's
more action to just playing golf which
is really cool
um so we're gonna back out and play a
different mode
what are we gonna play now theresa we
are gonna play all together all four of
us
oh boy we're gonna play speedgolf
love to play speedgolf yeah let's take a
minute to uh get set up here
yeah we are back and set up with motion
controls to play a little bit of
speedgolf
for player all right all right so we're
gonna start
up uh we're playing a local wireless
and it's gonna be two players on each
system
so two systems two games two players on
each
i will be selecting my me character
i'm going to play as king bo bom because
i'm a big fan that he is back
i'm daisy and i'm waluigi because of
that outfit
[Laughter]
sensible and we're going to be playing
on bonnie green's which again is the
birthplace
of uh golf mushroom kingdom yep
sounds perfect all right it's a nice
friendly game of golf and as you might
see we're
we're standing because we're playing
with motion controls and uh
the this version of speed golf is very
special because it's now playable in
motion controls but also you're able to
control the character on the course
which you'll see here in a bit
so uh it is really fun
it's a little chaotic really chaotic but
really zany and crazy
i live for chaos let's go for it guys
all right here we go
[Music]
and go all right all right
all right i can work with that let's go
so you see the stamina bar
on each character below each character
so we're using the motion controls to
jog
but we could also press the l button if
our stamina bar is still green to do a
special dash
which comes in handy if you run into
sheep or something on the course
explosive on his way when king obama's
coming by make room
the benefit to running you know is we
are playing speed golf
all about how fast you can get through
the course
yeah so each each stroke is worth 30
seconds on your score
sorry no you're not
i mean waluigi having a war here oh boy
all right
all right all right i got this daisy's
got to take a breather
oh here we go all right
all right oh my gosh oh stuck all right
all
right
all right let's do this i'm practicing
my swing here before i hit the ball
because i want to see how much power i
give
it oh come on birdie
oh so close waluigi's finding his own
adventure
yeah all right i'll take it tomorrow
thank you
thank you all right all right okay
nicely done
wait what's taking you guys so long hey
hey
i am wanting to
[Laughter]
all right
so majestic he really thank you esther
oh it's okay we'll make it look good
it'll work guys a few more holes you're
still warming up you know
theresa and robin been playing this
whole time but you and i you know
yeah he's wearing challenging shoes for
this to be fair
all right i got a
improve my game here i'd like to see you
try
let's do this so in speed golf the
uh we don't all start after the first
hole we don't all start at the same time
whoever did the best has to wait the
longest
to go and give people a chance to catch
up yup so i'm still waiting
all right here we go
[Music]
go go all right run daisy
special oh you ready
i went too far
you need to stop doing that i do i get
really excited with the special dashes
oh man
and in speedgolf you don't really want
to spend a lot of time reading greens
and things so you
kind of just have to hope
come on baby oh too far oh man get out
of my way
too far okay this is not boating well
i'm playing hops off with the flag right
now i have two
okay okay here we go here we go oh
nicely done theresa
that actually maybe next time that
worked out in my favor
hopefully okay
no pressure it is not
our character's fault it is us
[Laughter]
whatever double bogey crazy feels big
easy we got it we got it we got this we
got those
okay that was not my best hole
shaking it off so before it's so we're
all even because we're also playing for
time not just the number of strokes
so we'll see we see how we fare now this
last one this is the last one
this last one will be it i love it oh
god no
okay i have to wait until you guys go
all right well i like having the green
to myself go for a nice jog
yeah nothing more refreshing
catch up with you jokers oh boy
ah you almost hit me with your golf ball
i love
luigi oh all right what have we got here
oh this oh i'm just showing you oh
that's saucy all right all right
what that was probably a little bit too
much um
i love the special dashes they just
sound so satisfying
[Laughter]
and then it does it does uh because it's
an energy gauge
it does go off so you'll just have to
run
in order for it to build up again so you
can use it
okay um let's go like
oops we're just going to try to power
through those trees that's good
yeah i was wondering about that too yeah
i'm just going to power through those
trees too
yeah i'm sure that will end well for you
hey hey hey
hey
did we though i'm gonna practice this
okay or do i want to just crack because
i tend to be a little bit too excited
just like that all right
come on daisy come on you've got some
catching up to do girly
shot be my meme king coming through no
oh no too much um
same here oh you got a good bar
you guys boogie not too bad
not too bad you got this theresa i hope
so
let's see that was pretty nice yeah
but nice all right
i matched daisy here let's see
well you're a minute longer than me but
yeah that time was not in my favor so i
think
yep oh look at that best award goes to
oh and also the best that goes to
nicely done well done well done
applause all around congratulations
golf clap that was fun yeah that was fun
thanks for joining me on that adventure
guys
thanks for guiding us through a little
bit of mario golf super rush yeah
so before we close we do want to mention
that there will be
uh future updates for this game so
stick around for more information on uh
what that is
um and then as brandon had mentioned at
the beginning of the sem
the game is about to release in just a
couple weeks so
that's really exciting can't wait for
this game to come out yeah it comes out
uh june 25th
nintendo switch system so uh yeah that's
it for this segment thanks for joining
us
for a little bit of mario golf super
rush but don't go anywhere there's more
treehouse live nintendo trials live
coming up
we're going to show you some shin megami
tensei 5.